plus que de simples déclarations donald
trump et joe biden se livrent une
véritable guerre des mots objectif
décrédibiliser l'adversaire sur un sujet
des plus sensibles
le coc vide 19 le président américain
lui a une idée fixe la prochaine
découverte d'un vaccin d'ici au vote du
3 novembre qui pourrait tout changer
bah il donnait sa colistière très
libérale la personne la plus libérale au
congrès d'ailleurs n'est pas une
personne compétente à mon avis ils
détruiraient ce pays et ils détruiraient
cette économie il devrait immédiatement
s'excuser pour la rhétorique anti
vaccins imprudente dont il parle en ce
moment qui parle de mettre des vies en
danger et qui sape la science mais le
vaccin sera très sûr et très efficace il
sera livré très bientôt et vous pourriez
avoir une très grosse surprise
je suis sûr que vous serez très heureux
mais les gens seront heureux les gens du
monde seront heureux d'une conférence de
presse surprise en réponse aux propos
tenus quelques heures plus tôt par
kamala harris
la colistière du candidat démocrate joe
biden je prie pour que nous disposions
le plus rapidement possible d'un vaccin
approuvé par les scientifiques et les
professionnels de la santé publique
feriez-vous confiance à l'un d'entre eux
sous la direction du président trump
jean croirait ainsi les professionnels
de la santé publique et les
scientifiques nous disait que nous
pouvons lui faire confiance
cette défiance donald trump la fustige
alors que les etats-unis sont le pays le
plus touché par la pandémie de kovy 19
avec plus de 6 millions 300 mille cas et
bientôt 190 nick décès
parallèlement le président américain est
critiquée après que l'agencé américaine
du médicament a déclaré pouvoir délivrer
une autorisation d'urgence un futur
vaccin avant même la fin des essais
cliniques censé confirmer sa fiabilité
une décision qui sera scientifique a
toutefois tempéré l'autorité américaine
du médicament
cette dernière avait d'ailleurs autorisé
fin mars et l'hydroxyde chloroquine
vanté par donald trump avant de se
raviser en juin un double discours
taclé par joe biden qui multiplie les
déplacements dans des états clés l'un
des problèmes avec sa façon de jouer
avec la politique et qu'il dit tellement
de choses qui ne sont pas vrai que je
crains que même si nous avons un vrai
bon vaccin des personnes hésiteront à
aller se faire vacciner
ils savent donc la confiance du public
mais prions dieu que nous en ayons un si
je pouvais avoir un bon vaccin demain je
le ferai si cela me coûtait l'élection
je le ferai nous avons besoin d'un
vaccin et nous en avons besoin
maintenant le plus vite possible
les etats unis ont investi plus de 10
milliards de dollars dans la recherche
d'un vaccin
un vaccin miracle mais aussi
providentiel